[Musique]
enfin beau enfin chaud et enfin on peut
se réunir les parcs sont encore une fois
cette année deux grandes salles à manger
à ciel ouvert si on regarde juste les
bacs nature on a eu une augmentation
l'année passée de 70 % si l'on se trouve
dans chaque mot sonne qui est un parc de
quartier merci par classe est à peu près
sept à dix fois plus d'achalandage
quand il fait beau il fait chaud plus
d'achalandage mais aussi plus de traces
c'est le fun de partager cette grande
cuisine collective de l'eau mais on veut
pas partager vos reste la technique et
en prenant son temps ou launch et à
l'improviste manger dehors est devenue
l'activité sociale de leur part il fait
beau on va les manger au tac donc on
recommence des choses ici et là on se
retrouve sur une table de pique nique
mais notre impact est quand même
important ici oui mais c'est surtout
l'impact c'est l'emballage avec marlène
atkinson on s'est attablé pour analyser
certains produisent et emballages offert
pour manger en plein air ça le change et
non sans raison
il ya une évolution de la part du si on
décide de prendre balade bruit mais ce
non plus on se calme et on reste là je
vais aller à la poubelle
[Musique]
l'inévitable plastique crée encore bien
des soucis
en fait les plastiques s'est passé le 6
qu'on peut pas mettre pour risque est
présentement c'est donc lui vaut une
poubelle
c'est sain bon exemple de la foi et
l'emballage et la couchette vallée à la
poubelle poubelles qui débordent absence
de bacs de recyclage et encore moins de
baca matières compostables
on ne sait souvent pas quoi faire avec
les déchets à quelle fréquence et vider
ses poubelles là dans une journée
je n'aurais pas pour toi par jour c'est
vide et 3g idéalement sa secrète va
rapporter rapporter à la maison où on
peut le mettre dans le bon bac pour
s'assurer que soient recyclés si on est
vraiment mal pris mais n'importe quel
choix d'emballage qu'on va avoir fait
aurait été inutile parce que ça va aller
complètement la plus d'un mois ce que je
fais quand je frémis lunch dès
maintenant des plans plastique puis mon
club plastique devient mon bac de
déchets et de recyclage remettre seul
intérieur je m'en vais chez nous
pourquoi pâtissier pas les installations
où on s'en va manger
[Musique]
pour l'autriche 2-1 fumanal à pierre
manger dehors est une occasion gourmande
qui demande un minimum de préparation
j'oubliais poulet la planification va
au-delà de ce qu'on va manger
moi je suggère de faire le cycle complet
dans notre tête ou si vous êtes papier
fait que sur papier de l'expérience
pique nique au repos extérieur que vous
allez faire c'est à dire mais
premièrement il fait chaud et le froid
qu'est-ce qu'on a un goût de manger on
va être atteindre où on va être mangé
sur une table technique ou sur un rocher
on de montagne parce que tout soit
possible
effectivement tout est possible pour
manon même apporté sa poêle enfants pour
faire cuire sont pas d'or ce style 11.2
camping pique nique
honnêtement j'ai fait ma pâte maison les
pétri c'est sarrazin et blé c'est cuit
non un petit peu du loup qu'on amène un
petit bouteilles d'huile peut offrir le
bon niveau de friture et on peut en
faire un sandwich au pain trempé dans le
hamas et tant qu'à avoir sorti la poêle
en fonte on se paye la traite
moi j'aimerais sept souhaitent un pique
nique du bord la mer parce que tant qu'à
rêver bravant des petites patates
gabriel de l'île d'orléans de l'eau
salée de mer on pourrait le faire ici
avec de l'eau salée innovantes et on
couvre les pommes de terre crue d'eau
salée on laisse réduire et ce qui va
arriver c'est que le sel vont venir
s'attacher à la peau des pommes de terre
ils viennent super crémeuse à
l'intérieur comme si des petites pommes
de terre on fait juste une petite somme
pour les essentiels
on a souvent tout ce qu'il faut à la
maison mais quelques achats demeure
parfois nécessaire alors on a soif
oui on a soif et en a énormément de
choix le choix des meilleurs et les
moins bons et moins bons
le vert c'est celui qui la moins
dommageable
globalement parce que ils risquent la
balle elle finie et
parce qu'il est meilleur aucune
émanation c'est pas un plastique non
plus ce qui est important qu'on fait
notre choix
si au moins aller vers un qui serait peu
cyclables parce que l'objectif c'est pas
juste de le rejeter s'ils surviennent
aux trois r réduire réutiliser recycler
ces deux là étrangement c'est la même
matière donc on a du polystyrène dans
les deux ans n'était expansé et d'une
annexe pensez donc ces deux là ce n'est
j'étais absolument qu'on est mieux
privilégier ce thriller que de prendre
un pilote si on évite d'acheter du
jetable
il faut aussi faire attention aux
nouveaux matériaux dits plus écologique
que c'est vrai que c'est compostables
meilhon comme saisi cette opportunité
est de dire on va faire des trucs les
gens vont l'acheter mais en bout de
ligne on n'est pas plus avancé on est
capable de composter la matière
tous les restes de table mais ces
nouveaux objets là qui sont dits
compensable vont prendre plus de temps
une température plus élevée parce qu'on
n'arrivera pas à le composter battre
malheureusement ça s'envoie à
l'enfouissement
sûr qu'en cas de grands doutes on est
mieux de la mettre à la poubelle parce
que ça va juste avoir un impact négatif
sur toute les centres de tri et qu'on
est mieux d'y aller à la poubelle on
n'est pas certain
[Musique]
on laisse rien derrière je pense que là
n'est pas si ça a été une belle
démonstration les gens qui font du
camping du pique nique qui des fois
laissé trop de traces derrière donc on
pense à souffle
[Musique]